kikou les boys and girls déjà le
cinquième tuto cela de l'art moderne
c'est aujourd'hui une de leur mode end
spécial amour spéciales loeb
on a tous besoin de nous et je crois
j'avais mes voisins et cocumont camille
conclut bertrand où j'en connais un qui
revient de vacances allaient de leurs
modèles alors on démarre les garçons 5 6
on se retourne en garde loin devant red
carpet et là c'est tout c'est un câlin
qu'est-ce qui fait le poussin il a les
pieds en canard piou piou piou piou piou
piou a les attentions c'est le french
love love
allez c'est parti ouais le sourire le
sourire bravo mon bertrand tu l'as fort
et on voyage un petit peu maintenant
l'amour est universel il me semble c'est
la taille inné du love
il fait beau et on s'aime ouais ouais
donnant modem ont fini comment on
s'offre attention oui de leurs modèles
alors s'ils prennent de l'amour c'est le
prénom du love j'ai une petite surprise
pour vous je vais appeler deux de mes
petits choux qui sont avec nous ce soir
et beaucoup de cas plus beaucoup alors
oui je voulais dire un truc a déjà je
suis super contente ici pas là de leur
modèle ce et j'ai pensé à un pas qui
pourrait intéresser alors t'es gentil tu
penses à rien du tout comme d'habitude
ici et sur d8 vous êtes sûrement un
territoire vous avez compris ce que ça
veut dire
j'ai explosé sur d8 et oui il faudra s'y
faire sachez qu'ici c'est chez moi déjà
hanouna il lui reste coi en deux trois
mois d'existence sur cette chaîne
ensuite ce sera touche pas à ma danse et
avec qui billy phoques à la médiathèque
longtemps excuses à m est ce que tu peux
me re expliqué de retour à gacé mais ce
que c'est pénible de devoir faire ses
gaules en permanence la jambe gauche a
regardé les bosses comme ils ont bien et
on se retourne c'est compliqué ça je
crois pas non de leurs modèles toutefois
pendant ces cinq six sept musique
[Musique]
la de là
là
il y a deux
il
[Musique]
yeah
[Applaudissements]
bravo nos bertrand et surtout bravo chez
vous applaudissez vous embrassez vous si
la de lanrodec ou là de leur moulin va
pas bientôt 6e tuto sto lat à leurs
modèles
[Applaudissements]
la dollar hotel
revel